si vous vous promenez dans les rues de
dijon et que vous regardez par terre et
bien vous risquez de voir ce genre
d'objet une petite cartouche métalliques
il s'agit en fait est bien de protoxyde
d'azoté utilisés pour faire de la crème
chantilly
mais depuis peu son usage est détournée
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que l'on en
voit de plus en plus qui jonchent nos
rues c'est le matin avant le passage
d'évasion de propreté de la ville que
c'est le plus visible sur la place de la
république à proximité des
établissements nocturnes ou dans le
caniveau
ces petites fioles argenti font
désormais partie du paysage
un petit tour sur internet suffit à
constater l'ampleur du phénomène on y
trouve un tas de vidéos où l'on voit
deux jeunes gens inhalant ce gaz avec
comme résultat d'incontrôlable fous
rires le produit est en vente libre et
sur le web des sites de vente se sont
même spécialisés ils proposent des
cartouches mais également les crackers
et les ballons qui permette l'extraction
du gaz
et tout ça à bas prix
et vous savez ce que c'est ça c'est
ça je te drogue avec ça tullow tu le
mets dans le nez c'est c'est de la
drogue
les jeunes dijonnais semblent donc
connaître cette pratique au chu même si
aucune prise en charge n'a été lié à
cette mode on tient à alerter le
problème du protoxyde d'azoté comme
n'importe quel gaz si vous respirez que
du protoxyde d azote venaient plus
d'oxygène
donc si vous avez plus d'oxygène vous
allez faire un arrêt cardiaque hypoxique
cd vous allez vous endormirez faire un
arrêt cardiaque par défaut d'oxygène
dans le sang d'accord c'est ça qui tu
souhaites un accident qui va se produire
peut-être dans un pour cent des cas mais
si la l'utilisation du protoxyde d azote
festif se multiplient on aura forcément
des cas pour tenter d'enrayer le
phénomène en france plusieurs communes
ont pris des arrêtés pour interdire la
vente aux mineurs où la consommation de
ce produit sur la voie publique à dijon
cela ne devrait pas arriver
invité à réagir à notre reportage les
services de la mairie nous répondent que
ce n'est pas un sujet